the answer is we will store a function
object in that sagas array from the F to
the end curly brace is the definition of
a function object and that is the value
that we're pushing into the sagas array
a lexical scope is actually just
characters of code that you find in a
file somewhere and that's not actually a
value that can be stored anywhere in a
variable or as an element of an array an
execution context is one of these boxes
that we see pictured here wherein we
find stored key value pairs and
fundamentally this is not something you
can even have a reference to and
similarly it can't be stored in an array
there is no anonymous function being
called here the closest thing is this
function object but since there are no
parens appearing after it we will not be
invoking an anonymous function and
therefore we won't be getting the result
of an anonymous function